[Music]
good evening and welcome to a special
edition of tucker carlson tonight now
it's hard to have a lot of faith in
political polling obviously especially
after the last couple of presidential
elections
the polls weren't just wrong in those
elections they were insane they told us
things like oh no hillary could take
texas and joe biden's a lock to win
florida
in the end those predictions had no
relationship to observable reality
but that doesn't mean that all polling
is worthless actually as a relative
measure over time polls can provide a
lot of historical context
so joe biden's polls are in the toilet
right now everyone knows that and the
question is why you'll hear a lot of
people say well it was afghanistan the
true debacle that biden oversaw in
afghanistan the question is that really
it however is a foreign policy disaster
enough to knock a president off his game
in his first year in office well here
are some comparisons
gerald ford's approval ratings after the
fall of saigon those would be worth
looking at the fall of saigon was the
most humiliating moment in this
country's history up until that time the
entire world watched as americans ran
from a peasant army civilians dangled
from helicopters taking off from the
roof of the u.s embassy in saigon
it was a catastrophe one that became an
enduring symbol of the incompetence of
our foreign policy establishment
the us had spent more than a decade in
vietnam lost close to 60 000 men and
after all of that we ran away
and yet in the days after the fall of
saigon gerald ford's poll numbers as
measured by gallup actually went up his
approval rating increased from 39 to 40
percent then just a month later by the
end of may
1975 ford's approval rating surged to 51
percent
so gerald ford president ford oversaw an
international embarrassment but
americans
gave him a pass they weren't done with
them just yet
something very similar happened during
the john f kennedy administration
kennedy was in charge during the bay of
pigs invasion in april of 1961 which he
single-handedly turned into a disaster
that disaster made fidel castro a
national hero in cuba and drove cuba
even closer to the soviet union all this
happened just for the cuban missile
crisis
so that was not a good thing for anybody
and yet despite that jfk's approval
ratings did not drop in fact they went
up from 78 percent to 83 in the days
after the disaster
so the bay of pigs happened in the first
year of the kennedy administration the
fall of saigon happened in the first
year of the ford administration so it's
hard not to conclude that when
presidents are just starting out
americans give them a pass even on the
big things especially in foreign policy
so with that in mind it's worth taking a
look at how joe biden's approval numbers
have changed during his first year in
office and of course it's an unequivocal
disaster
according to a new quinnipiac poll only
36 percent of americans approve of the
job joe biden is doing in office the
real clear politics polling average has
joe biden doing only marginally better
at about 41 percent gallup has by knit
42 down 15 points from just a couple of
months ago
you should know that kamala harris's
approval number is 28 percent which is
right around jeffrey dahmer level
so two-thirds of americans do not want
joe biden to run for president again and
that includes most democrats
just 10 months into bison spiden's
presidency americans want him gone
so as a historical matter that's unheard
of how bad is it it's gotten so bad that
college students typically not a
right-wing demographic are mocking
mockingbiden at football games
[Applause]
so biden is deeply unpopular the
question is why how did we get here that
matters and that's going to be our focus
over the next hour on this show what
we're witnessing under the biden
administration is something americans
will absolutely not forgive
the decline in our standard of living
biden hasn't simply embarrassed the
united states internationally though
he's certainly done that
americans can overlook that as they did
under ford and jfk and hope for
something better next time
biden has made living in this country
much more difficult for millions of
people he's made it a lot harder for
americans to afford basic amenities
things like building supplies and
gasoline
and then he showed almost no interest in
fixing this in fact it's clear it's
being done on purpose because global
warming
one local news station in florida has
talked to restaurant owners about the
effect of rising food prices for example
watch this
from chicken wings it's a hundred and
forty dollars a case versus what was
forty dollars two plastic gloves they've
gone from twenty dollars a case to 140
plus
and again sometimes it's hard to get
those nearly everything costs more john
horn on frla's executive committee also
owns anna maria oyster bars supply
issues are keeping favorites like
alaskan king crab legs and clam strips
off the menu one of our most popular
items can't get them from anyone
according to the bureau of labor
statistics major commodities in the
wholesale food price index are way up
since last year beef rose 57.7 percent
fat and oils nearly 50 percent eggs
almost 40 percent and processed poultry
30 percent to offset that menu prices on
average are up 4.7 percent
what is this exactly we can't get enough
food
a lot of things are happening and one of
them is inflation and inflation is not
an act of god it's the result of
government policy the federal reserve
has devalued the u.s dollar by printing
too many u.s dollars why are they
printing them to pay for more government
spending spending that under the bide
administration is now literally out of
control
there was a 10.1 trillion dollar amount
of spending obligations in fiscal year
2020 10.1 trillion
2019 which wasn't ancient history was
the other day the total was 6.6 trillion
still a lot
but very different than 10.1
now the spending is of course on the way
more spending is on the way because we
can spend any amount of money we hold
the world's reserve currency
by the so-called build back better bill
is estimated to cost another five
trillion dollars
so the people who are printing this
money the us congress the fed
specifically know that they are making
the problem worse but they don't care
in fact they're mocking you for noticing
that your standard of living has
declined the st louis fed is to release
this statement
it's hard to miss the contempt here this
is real quote a thanksgiving dinner
serving of poultry cost one
dollar 42 cents a soybean based dinner
serving with the same amount of calories
costs 66 cents and provides almost twice
as much protein
end quote
of course being soy based also lowers
your testosterone level which of course
is the entire point of this but it's
just interesting that the fed which is
supposed to be focused on keeping
inflation under control that's why we
have a fed
is now telling you what to eat
how did this happen how much are they
telling you to eat bugs to stop climate
change not far not far from that at all
in the bite administration a host of
bureaucratic agencies are suddenly in
charge of your body the minute details
of your body what you have for
thanksgiving dinner
the white house believes that osha for
example can tell you what to inject into
your body get the injection or you're
fired now you remember that just a few
months ago the white house was saying
the opposite of this vaccine mandates
are illegal i don't think it should be
mandatory i wouldn't demand to be
mandatory but i would do everything in
my power just like i don't think masks
have to be made mandatory nationwide can
we mandate vaccines across the country
no that's not a role that the federal
government i think even has the power to
make we cannot require someone to be
vaccinated
that's just not what we can do
it is a matter of privacy to know who is
or who isn't no definitely not you don't
want to mandate and try and force anyone
to take a vaccine we've never done that
we don't want to be mandating from the
federal government to the general
population it would be unenforceable and
not appropriate
these people are reckless and crazy and
dishonest and the rest of us put up with
it
after all that after everything you just
saw of course they mandated the
injections they knew that was illegal
just as we saw with the eviction ban
they did it anyway then the airlines
started canceling flights the health
care workers disappeared because somehow
politicians know more about corona
than nurses how does that work
they did it anyway they ran out of truck
drivers to pick up goods from reports
first responders were fired you couldn't
get an ambulance
and joe biden stands up at a town hall
and says they had it coming
yeah the little people getting uppity
we're gonna hurt them and he definitely
hurt them
so this is brazen
most people are very tired of it it's
not a partisan question do you want to
live in a functional country or don't
you
the question is how are we
going to survive three more years of
this that's a very good question hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else